ya sé lo que estáis pensando de verdad
podemos decir que el socialismo está tan
pasado de moda como el messenger de
windows en europa lo sé muchos pensaréis
que esto es solamente una opinión pero
antes de que os lancéis a escribir en la
sección de comentarios mirad este mapa
[Música]
en este mapa podéis ver los gobiernos
socialdemócratas que quedan en europa en
este momento si os fijáis apenas hay
países en rojo y algunos como en españa
se están desplomando en las encuestas es
decir que no es una opinión que tengamos
aquí en visual político es un hecho los
partidos socialdemócratas tienen menos
poder cada día y alguno todavía me dirá
a ver fonseca el fútbol y la democracia
son así unas veces ganas las elecciones
y otras veces pierdes las elecciones el
problema el problema es que hay muchos
países en europa donde los socialistas
ya no son ni siquiera la segunda fuerza
política y esto es una tendencia que se
viene dando desde la crisis financiera
de 2004
queréis un ejemplo os doy un ejemplo
francia durante décadas francia fue un
país y partidista las principales
fuerzas políticas eran la centroderecha
y los socialistas pues bien desde hace
años la batalla política está entre los
ultranacionalistas de marín le pen y los
liberales de macrón los socialistas han
quedado relegados a la posición del
y algo parecido podría pasar en alemania
pero qué me decís de grecia los
socialdemócratas del pasado que están al
borde de desaparecer habéis oído bien
dicho de otra forma el problema no es
que los socialistas estén perdiendo
elecciones el problema es que pueden
dejar de ser un partido de gobierno de
nuevo esto no es una opinión es algo muy
real que está pasando y si no cambia
mucho las cosas podría darse
definitivamente y qué me decís de los
países que sí tienen gobiernos
socialistas en este momento por ejemplo
dinamarca si es cierto dinamarca tiene
un gobierno socialdemócrata presidido
por una mujer que se llama mete
frederiksen
ahora bien esta señora no se parece en
nada a lo que os podríais imaginar por
una socialista nórdica su política de
inmigración hace que viktor orbán o
santiago abascal parezcan unos hippies
abraza árboles se ha llegado a
comprometer a tener cero refugiados así
tal cual como lo he dicho de otra forma
que el socialismo parece que está al
borde de desaparecer y los pocos
socialistas que quedan están mutando en
cosas que se parece muy poco al
socialismo o la socialdemocracia que
habíamos conocido hasta ahora dicho de
otra forma los socialistas están en una
crisis de identidad donde hay tres
tribus luchando los socialistas truco la
tercera ola y los posmodernos y no está
claro quién de ellos puede ganar o si
saldrá una nueva tribu
consiga reencauzar a la socialdemocracia
y ya sé lo que se estaría preguntando
muchos pero como es esto posible a fin
de cuentas en este momento hay más
multimillonarios que nunca mucha gente
dice que las desigualdades entre ricos y
pobres son cada vez más profundas
entonces por qué tanta gente en europa
ha dejado de votar a partidos
socialistas que está pasando existe
alguna forma de resucitar a la
socialdemocracia en europa hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
antes les tengo que recomendar un nuevo
canal de youtube en el que colabora
visual política hablamos de si lo
hubiera sabido el nuevo canal de
actualidad financiera creado por
mutuactivos
[Música]
y
en este nuevo canal vais a descubrir
todas las tendencias más importantes que
se mueven en el mundo de las finanzas
por ejemplo puede ser rentable invertir
en empresas sostenibles cómo podemos
usar la bolsa para proteger nuestros
ahorros de la inflación cómo se está
comportando el mercado de valores en la
salida de la pandemia todas estas son
preguntas a las que se responden en este
canal todo esto por supuesto sin clic
byte y sensacionalismo y con muchísimo
rigor os dejo el link en la descripción
y ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de
historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la primera pregunta que nos tenemos que
hacer es y es la clase obrera pensando
bien si hay algo que define a los
socialistas es precisamente la clase
obrera sobre los partidos llamados a
representar a los proletarios ahora bien
qué es un obrero como se define pues
bien según carl marx los obreros son
aquellos que no tienen la propiedad de
los medios de producción es decir que
según el marxismo podríamos dividir a la
sociedad en dos grupos los capitalistas
que tienen las empresas y las fábricas y
los trabajadores que son los que ponen
la mano de obra cobran un sueldo y no
tienen propiedad sobre los medios del
capital
[Música]
y queréis entender mejor el marxismo os
dejo un link en la descripción donde
explicamos es el machismo con más
detalle os aviso que es uno de nuestros
primeros vídeos donde todavía tenía pelo
hecha esta aclaración nuestra historia
empieza en el año 1918 este es el año
del choque definitivo entre socialistas
y comunistas los dos tenían el mismo
objetivo acabar con el capitalismo y
establecer una dictadura del
proletariado la diferencia es que los
comunistas lo hicieron mediante una
revolución violenta en rusia mientras
que los socialdemócratas lo querían
conseguir ganando elecciones en
democracias liberales es decir sacando
leyes nuevas y haciendo una transición
gradual hacia el socialismo
pero no os podéis imaginar los
marchistas puros decían que los
socialdemócratas eran unos ilusos que
creían que podían cambiar el sistema
desde dentro y que tarde o temprano
terminarían pareciendo si el enemigo sin
embargo la historia ha demostrado que
los socialdemócratas tenían su parte de
razón sí es cierto los marxistas
ortodoxos tuvieron sus revoluciones en
los países agrícolas países como rusia o
como china pero sin embargo en europa
industrial y rica los comunistas
tuvieron poco que decir ésta fue el
feudo de los socialdemócratas
por eso en el año 1918 alemania fue el
primer país del mundo en tener un
gobierno socialdemócrata pensando bien
si la política fuera un mercado de ideas
los socialistas tenían el producto
perfecto iba dirigido hacia el grupo
mayoritario que eran los obreros daos
cuenta que hablamos del año 1918 casi
toda la economía se basaba en la
industria de unos pocos capitalistas
dominaban las empresas y el resto eran
obreros obreros que eran potenciales
votantes del partido socialdemócrata
alemán así es como comenzó el boom del
socialismo
[Música]
los alemania llegaron los países
nórdicos suecia noruega dinamarca que
todos ellos eran también economías con
enormes sectores industriales todos
ellos eran el caldo de cultivo perfecto
para que arrasarán los partidos
socialdemócratas
pero esperad un momento porque esto es
solo el principio en el año 1929 ocurrió
algo que disparó el éxito de la
socialdemocracia hasta convertirlo en
una ideología hegemónica si mis queridos
amigos de visual política hablamos del
crack del 29 el gran colapso del sistema
financiero
en su momento los partidos políticos que
defendían el libre mercado perdieron
toda la credibilidad y la mayoría de los
votantes pasaron a votar a partidos de
izquierdas partidos que defendían los
intereses de los obreros desde eeuu
hasta los países nórdicos todos los
gobiernos democráticos se reinventan y
si pensabais que la segunda guerra
mundial truncó toda esta oleada
socialista os equivocáis desde los años
40 hasta los años 80 a todo el mundo
desarrollado abrazó un sistema económico
contra el estado jugaba un rol
fundamental en las empresas
esta es la época del nacimiento del
estado del bienestar la economía
keynesiana los impuestos altos y las
grandes empresas públicas los
socialistas estaban on fire vale no
podían derribar al capitalismo
definitivamente pero estaba claro que
eran capaces de reformar los sin embargo
todo esto cambió en los años 70 el
modelo socialdemócrata se hundió y diez
años después también cayó la unión
soviética de repente la idea de acabar
con el capitalismo lentamente o de forma
revolucionaria dejó de ser tan atractiva
así que tanto los socialistas como los
comunistas dejaron de ganar las
elecciones pero si pensabais que este
fue el fin del socialismo en europa os
equivocáis los socialistas no murieron
simplemente evolucionaron
y así es como nació la llamada tercera
ola la tercera ola fue la respuesta de
la izquierda a la caída del socialismo
real y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos la tercera ola fonseca pero que
me estás contando si ese fue el momento
en el que los socialdemócratas
terminaron de vender su alma al
capitalismo si eso es lo que dirían
tanto los comunistas como los
socialistas clásicos los socialistas
trump pero lo cierto es que la tercera
ola y que los partidos socialistas
volvieran a arrasar en distintas
elecciones esta es la época de tony
blair en reinounido your heart schréder
en alemania y hasta josé luís rodríguez
zapatero en españa de hecho más o menos
los años 90 y 2000 fueron los auténticos
años dorados de la izquierda en europa
sin embargo ahora las cosas han cambiado
y diréis porque pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
dónde está la clase obrera si alguno de
vosotros está afiliado algún partido de
izquierdas seguro que habréis oído una y
mil veces el problema de los socialistas
es que se han olvidado de la clase
obrera la pregunta es quién es clase
obrera hoy en día por ejemplo si nos
vamos a la definición original de carl
marx los obreros son los que cobran un
salario y no tienen la propiedad de los
medios de producción el problema es que
según esta definición es casi anabella
el ceo de microsoft es clase obrera no
no me he vuelto loco el ceo de cualquier
empresa es un trabajador que cobra un
sueldo que el sueldo se lo pone la junta
de accionistas que son los que sí tienen
la propiedad de los medios de producción
sin embargo nadie se imagina a un súper
directivo afinando si un sindicato
verdad pues evidentemente no lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es redefinir lo
que entendemos por clase obrera
podríamos decir que los obreros son
aquellos que tienen empleos no
cualificados es decir gente que trabaja
en trabajos mecánicos que no requieren
un título universitario lo que en eeuu
llaman trabajadores de cuello azul hasta
los años 80 este era el grupo
mayoritario en toda europa pero hoy en
día la realidad es muy distinta atentos
a esta gracia
en esta gráfica podéis ver como cada vez
hay menos obreros en francia- hemos
utilizado el ejemplo de francia pero
podríamos haber usado casi cualquier
otro país europeo los trabajos manuales
están en peligro de extinción y la nueva
clase laboral mayoritaria en toda europa
son los profesionales es decir la gente
que ha ido a la universidad y trabaja en
oficinas suponen ya más del 20 por
ciento de la fuerza laboral en europa
pensando bien casi toda la industria se
ha marchado de europa china y otros
países asiáticos y las nuevas fábricas
no se parecen en nada a las fábricas del
siglo 20
antes hacían falta cientos de
trabajadores de cadena para producir
algo como un automóvil ahora ese trabajo
lo hacen robots y los pocos trabajadores
que utilizan estos robots son ingenieros
o gente que ha ido a la universidad no
me creéis pues vamos a viajar al país
obrero por excelencia francia habéis
oído bien francia ha sido un país famoso
por sus huelgas sus protestas y sus
sindicatos ese sin duda alguna francia
sin embargo cuántos trabajadores están
afiliados a sindicatos en este país pues
atentos a esta gráfica
[Música]
si os dais cuenta los sindicatos
llegarán a su pico a finales de los años
70 a partir de ahí no han dejado de caer
ahora sólo el 8% de la población laboral
francesa está sindicada y francia es
solamente un ejemplo porque podríamos
haber mostrado una gráfica muy parecida
si habláramos de españa reino unido o
casi cualquier otro país europeo la
única excepción que hemos encontrado es
bélgica que por alguna razón mantiene
una afiliación sindical del 50 por
ciento porque pues eso es tema para otro
vídeo ella se lo que me diera alguno en
serio de verdad me está diciendo fonseca
que la clase obrera ha desaparecido pero
eso no es posible todavía sigue habiendo
un montón de grupos que viven en una
situación marginal hay ricos y hay
pobres y sin tener razón pero esos
pobres ya no son obreros
[Música]
os doy un ejemplo si veis este vídeo
desde españa ya sabéis que la economía
española va de mal en peor todos los
datos apuntan a que cada vez hay más
desigualdad entre ricos y pobres pero
los pobres ya no son los obreros sino
los parados el 40% de los jóvenes
españoles están en el paro como os
podéis imaginar si un político se acerca
un joven en el paro para hablarle de
derechos laborales y sindicatos el joven
le dirá si todo esto está muy bien sería
fantástico si tuviera un trabajo pero
esperad un momento porque no hemos
terminado está tendencia empezó a
principios de los años 2000 ese fue el
momento en el que la clase obrera empezó
a desaparecer en europa pero el año en
el que comenzó el auténtico descalabro
del socialismo fue el año 2008
[Música]
habéis oído bien ese fue el año de la
gran crisis financiera muchos pensaréis
pero cómo es posible la crisis
financiera fue el colapso del libre
mercado la prueba de que el
neoliberalismo había fracasado verdad
sin embargo desde el punto de vista
electoral ocurrió exactamente lo
contrario queréis un ejemplo os doy un
ejemplo grecia
el partido socialdemócrata griego el
llamado paso era uno de los dos grandes
partidos en este país para que os hagáis
una idea en el año 2009 llegaron a tener
el 43 9% de los votos seis años más
tarde en 2015 el pasok se quedó con sólo
un
4,68 por ciento del voto y si habéis
oído bien ni siquiera llegaron al 5 por
ciento y hoy en día en 2021 los números
siguen siendo muy parecidos el pasado
que ha pasado de ser un partido de
gobierno va a ser un club con menos
gente que la biblioteca del barrio y
diréis y cuál es la solución que pueden
hacer los socialistas para recuperar la
confianza de los votantes que puede
hacer un europeo cuando se queda sin
ideas dónde puede encontrar inspiración
pues atentos
[Música]
mirando a los americanos ya los irse a
eeuu a copiar ideas no parece la cosa
más anticapitalista del mundo pero
seamos honestos eeuu tiene la política
más profesionalizada del mundo los
asesores de campaña en eeuu utilizan
encuestas estudios de mercado y bases de
datos para hacer campañas y todo esto
explica que la izquierda en este país
fuera la primera en darse cuenta de la
clase obrera
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en el año
1980 el 20% de los empleos en este país
eran de industria en 2016 era sólo del
8% en 1979 los sindicatos de eeuu tenían
a 20 millones de afiliar en 2013 con una
población mucho más grande sólo había 14
millones de afiliados pero esperad un
momento porque esto no es todo alguno
podría pensar que la clase obrera es más
propensa a votar a partidos de izquierda
verdad esta es la premisa sobre la que
hemos partido desde el principio de este
vídeo verdad sin embargo desde hace
décadas las encuestas de opinión dicen
justo todo lo contrario
[Música]
si entendemos que la cevr era como
trabajos de cuello azul tenemos que ser
obreros es un predictor de votar al
partido republicano si habéis oído bien
por supuesto no estamos diciendo que
todos los obreros voten al partido
republicano pero sí podemos decir que el
partido republicano es la opción
preferida en este grupo de hecho de otra
forma que dividir la sociedad por clases
ya no es una buena estrategia para
cosechar votos al menos no lo es si eres
un político de izquierdas sin embargo
hay otra forma de clasificar a la
sociedad que sí puede funcionar sabéis
quién si vota mayoritariamente a
partidos de izquierdas las minorías
raciales tanto los hispanos como los
afroamericanos sí son mucho más
propensos a votar a los demócratas así
es cómo nacieron las llamadas políticas
de identidad
y también así es cómo surgió una nueva
ideología una ideología que no es ni
comunismo ni socialismo ni tampoco
tercera ola hablamos del posmodernismo
izquierda posmoderna ya no se centra
tanto en la igualdad material como en
las políticas orientadas a la identidad
creo que no hace falta que os expliqué
más basta con que escuchéis el discurso
de cualquier político de izquierdas en
vuestros respectivos países para que
sepa es exactamente de lo que hablamos a
no ser que viváis en perú en cuyo caso
es otra historia el problema que qué
pasa cuando se intentan importar estas
políticas en europa pues el principal
problema es que cuantos afroamericanos
ahí en europa de verdad hay tantas
minorías raciales oprimidas de verdad
podemos decir que europa tiene la misma
estructura social que eeuu pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el fin del socialismo en estos momentos
todos los partidos socialistas tienen
una guerra abierta una batalla entre los
socialistas clásicos la tercera ola y
los posmodernos en reinounido intentaron
volver a sus orígenes y todo esto
explicó el ascenso de jeremy corbyn como
líder del partido laborista
[Música]
jeremy corbyn era una vuelta a la
esencia del socialismo y diréis que fue
en las últimas elecciones pues podéis
juzgar por vosotros en es general es de
2019 la peor noche de los laboristas
desde 1935 en españa estamos viendo algo
muy parecido españa como sabéis gobierna
el partido socialista junto a podemos
que es un partido de extrema izquierda
durante años españa era la excepción a
la regla parecía que era el último
bastión del socialismo en europa sin
embargo las encuestas empiezan a sonar
cada vez peor para el gobierno de
españa' y sólo hace falta mirar este
mapa para entender que lo que os estamos
contando es muy muy muy real
y ahora os preguntaréis hacia dónde van
todos los votos que antes iban hacia
partidos socialistas pues parte de la
respuesta también la tenéis en este mapa
si os fijáis no solo hay países rojos y
azules también tenemos países azul
oscuro y países naranjas los países azul
oscuro son los países con un gobierno de
derecha nacionalista pero los naranjas
son el centro liberal estas dos
corrientes ideológicas son cada vez más
importantes en algunos países como
francia podríamos decir que son ya el
nuevo bipartidismo es decir que ya no
hablamos de socialistas contra
conservadores sino de nacionalistas
contra liberales otros países como
alemania están viendo también el ascenso
de otras corrientes ideológicas como los
ecologistas
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros verdad estamos ante el fin del
socialismo queremos como otras
corrientes ideológicas lo reemplazan o
veremos una cuarta ola que consiga que
los partidos socialistas vuelvan a tener
una nueva era dorada podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
recordad visitar si lo hubiera sabido
que ya sabéis que es el nuevo canal de
finanzas de mutuactivos en el que
colaboramos nosotros visual político que
os aseguro que os va a gustar y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a este canal
y darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]